everybody Sean McGuinness and Carolyn
Pettit here at the Sony Playstation
showcase Santa Monica we just had a
chance to go hands-on with infamous
second son in some PlayStation 4 and
this one's interesting because we got to
check out the two different branch and
pathways of the game right you were good
yes I was very evil be back let's talk
about the setup how does this demo begin
okay so my mission the mission that I
played involved going to check out some
houseboats because there were rumors
that a drug cartel was operating out of
there you find a few a few house boats
that are in fact housing you know drugs
and drug dealers and you know you
basically end up having to use your
elemental powers to plot to zap and you
know so even though i chose the good
mission in combat I still kind of
obliterated a lot of enemies which is
when you when you had shot them
basically with your hours yeah and
that's kind of it the evil you know that
Nets you the bat the evil karma right
and the other option i think is you can
kind of shoot them in the shins
and then they then they can be subdued
it's a non-lethal way of taking them out
right now the mission that I did is you
know when you encounter fetch and you
have that choice do i do I kind of like
turn her and do I find the good in her
or do I find the evil in her and really
exploit that the latter is what I did so
I corrupted her and I said you know what
fetch what we're gonna do we're gonna go
find these anti conduit protesters we're
gonna beat them down we're gonna silence
though so these are not people with like
weapons or super powers right these are
just kind of people with like sine x
yeah okay so you go around evil you
rough them up a little bit yeah and but
then it's actually the DUP guards who
come after you and these are the like
this is the kind of quasi military
organization yeah the kind of
paramilitary so keeping the peace in
Seattle right right and I rough them up
and pretty much went nuts on those guys
but I you know I was just really amazed
by just the hemisphere yeah the city
looks more dream really it really does
and there's some really interesting
visual touches like when you see the way
you can tell that fetch has been in an
area is that she leaves these kind of
light trail right same light shows that
you would see in like a long exposure
camera show those kind of like willowy
ghosty kind of thing exactly she's
referred to like a nickname for her is
laser girl and actually one part of my
mission after I took care of things at
the Harbor we had to follow a truck and
and so she was just zipping across
rooftops and I was basically just
following her laser trail yeah across
the city and it was a really you know
beautiful visual effect yeah I mean I is
my first time to check out the game I'm
excited to play the full thing which is
not really that far off oh it's like a
month away
mark yeah yeah all right so there you
have it that's our updated impressions
on infamous second son the ps4 check out
more coverage coming to gamespot soon